hey guys hey fam so we are here because
we wanted to give you a quick message
before you see the podcast we recorded
with freely I can't even guarantee it's
gonna be quick it might be a message
yeah
we wanted to come on here and just have
a chat with you guys first ah because we
really felt like this was necessary for
this week
yes so we're going to have a quick talk
with you and then later in this episode
you will see our podcast with freely
really quick this entire podcast is
brought to you by me undies the sexiest
underwear in the game the softest
underwear in the game Oh micro modal
fabric twice the softest cotton it says
hey cotton I just beat you out get 20%
off your order guys go to me undies comm
slash Jenna Julian that's me undies calm
/join Julian this podcast is also
brought to you by bull and branch
softest bedding I've ever slept on most
quality bedding towels sheets duvet
covers everything you need Boleyn branch
has you covered quality quality
luxurious bedding for very affordable
prices you can get 20% off your entire
order when you use product code Jenna
Julian and go to bowl and branch comm
that's Bo LL and branch comm code Jenna
Julian thank you to our sponsor Thank
You sponsors so I will let you begin
alright I'll begin okay um we really
strongly felt like we needed to make
this message right now because we had
freely on the podcast freely as a
youtuber she's a vegan youtuber and we
have never in the past had any sort of
opposition to a guest and first and
foremost we want to let you know that we
have heard you we have read your
comments we understand where you're
coming from and we hear you and we care
and this is our podcast but this is very
much a two-way street
and I want you to know that you know
maybe this was something that I thought
was a good idea and
I still think is a good idea because I
do think it's important that everyone
does have a voice and including yours
including mine including yours and
including freelee's and I want you to
know how much we hear your voices when
you say that you do not want freely on
the podcast you do not want to hear her
you not want to listen to her because
you think that she is a bully she does
things that you don't like and I
understand you your valid in your
feelings I hear you and we are listening
to you and there are many people out
there that are fans of freely and I
think the best way to do this was that
in full disclosure we did edit down the
podcast a lot we at probably about half
yeah and things that we cut out of the
podcast where general vegan talk because
the first half-hour of the podcast was
general vegan talk the second half was
broken down into discussing her current
situation with Blogilates which is a
copyright issue on YouTube and the
second half was her current thing going
on with Tana mojo which we decided to
cut out because but you can see on both
of their channels pretty much what's
going on and we just talked to her about
that we left in Blogilates because we
felt like that was kind of an
interesting topic that had not been
talked about very much so we left out a
weak cut the Tana part and is most uh
related to what we do on this podcast
channel in the first place
but just in case you're miss you're
wondering what you miss Santana mojo we
all liked Anna mojo everyone likes Anna
they just had the you know video back
and forth we talked about it um but uh I
think something that might help right
now is if I disclose why I agreed to
have we agreed to have but mostly me
agreed to have freely on the podcast
even though so many of you in hindsight
after the fact once you realized that we
did it we're very angry about it and I
can only speak for myself that's that's
all I have so I would like to just
disclose to you why I made that decision
and why I
feel okay sitting in a room with freely
and having a real human talk with her
first of all I think that everyone
deserves to have an opinion and a voice
so even you know if I was not a vegan or
our views does not align in any of those
respects I would still like to sit in a
room and hear someone express why they
think a certain way or feel a certain
way but also because and I say a little
bit of this in the podcast I found out
who she was many years ago because she
made a video of me that was like jenna
Marbles gained weight after going off
her vegan diet and I was getting flooded
with tweets and everything being like
Jana dragged her like she made this
video calling you fat Jana dragged her
and I clicked on the video and I watched
it and at that point I had already been
back and forth vegan once or twice I
think like a year of those was a solid
year of being vegan and I realized that
she really wasn't calling me fat she
really wasn't doing the direction if she
wasn't doing what I was told she was
doing and that she just was a really
passionate vegan and made this this
here's this stranger you know across the
world in Australia that was so
passionately vegan that had realized
that I had become unbeaten and I took
that entire video as wow this is
actually completely flattering that
someone cares about me that much I was
sort of at a weird time in my life when
she made that I think I'm pretty sure I
just broken up with my boyfriend at the
time like I really felt like someone
cared about me enough to make that video
and that was a very unpopular opinion
most people saw it as clickbait they saw
it as you know her making fun of me and
I just did not feel any of that and I
type that in the comments and I told
freely how I felt and I felt the same
way about her ever since which I sort of
thought people knew that I didn't mind
freely and I can only speak for myself
and I want to emphasize that again if
you're upset at her for making other
videos about what you're in that video
or even this video you are entitled to
feel the way that you feel about her and
the content that she makes if she's made
videos in the past of upset you if she
said things in the past that upset you
and freelee's boyfriend as well they've
said things in the past that have hurt
and offended you you are entitled to
your feelings and to feel the way that
you can I really want you guys not to
feel like because they were in our house
on our podcast having conversations with
us that we automatically aligned with
things that they've done my everyone is
their own person and we you know part of
us hearing what you have said includes
the fact that maybe you were personally
offended by something they've said in
the past and you were hurt that we would
kind of welcome welcome them onto our
platform and identify with them we want
you to know just because we gave them a
voice just because we had them on as a
guest it doesn't automatically lump
everything they've said in you know with
our opinions and vice versa you know we
don't know them we had a nice encounter
and that was that was about yeah and and
this might be something that happens
again in the future that we have a guest
on where you feel strongly about we want
you to know that we are listening to you
we will always listen to you and that
your voice matters and uh it just
because maybe someone's beliefs don't
align with yours or mine or Julian's
it's okay to sit and kind of have a
conversation with them or to listen to
them and listening to this podcast is a
is a choice as well you don't have to
listen to the rest of this podcast if
you don't want to and I think that's
kind of the point sometimes to have a
podcast is that maybe you're sitting
next to somebody that you have a
completely different view of things
about and that's okay and in the bigger
picture you know maybe the way that I
feel about veganism are you or freely or
strategies online or you know what she
makes or does for a living if you don't
agree with that at all that's okay
and you can still like someone ah for
certain parts of them and not like other
parts of them you know like it's like
having a brother that just [ __ ] loves
some music that you hate I will still
love my brother
I mean it there I hope that if for some
reason this podcast makes you upset or
makes you think less of me or less of
Julian or less of freely or anything
like that that that's okay you are
entitled to feel and think the way that
you feel and to voice that to us because
we are listening to you we do hear you
but just to fully disclose why I decided
to have her on here it was because I
have never really seen what she did to
me personally as bullying and I was not
affected by it and some of the comments
are people on those particular videos
about me it did feel a little bit like I
was being told how to process this and I
didn't feel that way I felt like she was
coming from a place of caring and I
always understood that and that's why to
me it meant a lot that she made that
video it meant a lot whenever she would
check in on me in terms of
accountability because it served a
purpose for me in my life and it helped
me ultimately become the person that I
wanted to be and I appreciated that help
and I appreciated the support from her
um you never have to feel that way if
you never have to feel what I feel at
all she's made a video about you or that
hurt your feelings or anything like that
you're entitled to feel everything that
you feel um but that's why I decided I
would like to meet freely and I would
like to have around the podcast I think
that might make for an interesting
discussion and that's that's about all I
can say but other than that it's this is
a two-way street and I do want you to
feel like you you can tell us like hey
Jenna hey Julian I'm not comfortable
with this and I would appreciate the
thoughtful discussions to carry on in
the comments that you guys have been
having if you don't want to watch it at
all please don't please check back in
next week we'll see you next time for
something different
but that's pretty much what I got and I
want to just second that as much as I
possibly can
that we we do listen and we value your
opinions very very much I also feel like
this is a great learning experience for
us for everybody for everyone moving
forward for the podcast
and just kind of in general I do feel
like this will serve us for making
decisions that we can be ready for yeah
you know and and I mean that the best
way possible you know you were just
saying sometimes we'll have a guest that
you just you know necessarily won't
agree with everything they say or their
values or their content which I agree
even just us together absolutely and I
do appreciate that about the podcast I
think that's a very cool thing that
maybe every single podcast isn't for you
you know with all of that said if you
have made it this far
right now maybe you will get something
out of the conversation that takes place
with freely given that we we we tried to
formulate it in something that wouldn't
just rather everyone the wrong way we
wanted to make it accessible we wanted
to be fair too freely but also very much
to you guys because that was important
to me also you know we invited freely on
the podcast and I know that there are
freely fans out there that are looking
forward to hearing her and what she has
to say and I wanted to be fair to
freelee's time and Harleys time for
coming here and doing this with us and
we didn't want to not show any of it and
I'm not saying that we won't ever post
the full version but for now to in this
given circumstance we wanted to really
let you guys know that you're being
heard and uh it's I don't want to
overstep my boundaries or Julian
overstepped his boundaries in terms of
creating something that you guys really
don't want I'd say maybe it's not half
and half of want and don't want or not
feedback or you know we don't know how
many people want or don't want this
there was enough for us today it was
enough for us to at least let you know
that we care we're listening to you and
we're not just going to post something
with that amount of backlash and not
have you feel like you're being heard
and we really do hear you
is why we chop this down into uh you
know some general vegan talk and the
part of the podcast that at least
explains a little bit of my relationship
with freely and why I enjoy what she has
done for me personally and the part that
has to do with copyright because it fits
in the best probably with this
particular podcast but that's it and I
I'm trying my best I'm just a person
Julian is just a person it's not like we
have people helping us tell us what to
do in situations like this I hope that
you know that we are doing the best that
we can with this particular situation
and that we're trying to handle it in a
way that is fair to everyone um and that
we care that's it we care about
everybody we care that's it yeah okay
that's good um thank you guys for for
everything for having an honest
discussion with us and an honest line of
communication with us always means a lot
to us and you showing up here means a
lot to us so if you'd like to listen
please continue here's a short word from
our sponsors yeah and if you don't want
to listen that's okay we'll see you guys
next week
yeah and and thanks for being fam and
thanks for you know telling us uh you're
honest and open feedback and we're here
to listen so thanks guys this episode of
the Genna Julie podcast is brought to
you by me undies guys what are you
wearing a suit or sweats you spend
almost 24 hours a day in your underwear
but instead of making a statement like
Superman tights in his everyday clothes
your underwear is probably boring me
undies can change that guy's it is
literally twice as soft as cotton they
use a fabric called micro modal fabric
and you don't really understand what
that means since that you put on a pair
me undies has such a comfortable fit and
if you don't love your first pair of
neon DS they're free no questions asked
me and each has dozens of styles limited
edition prints you guys have seen them
in my vlogs you've seen them kind of
everywhere because they have new designs
all the time and they're crazy
comfortable the shipping in the u.s. is
free and Canada
and you can save up to $8 a pair with me
and a subscription plan right now you
can get subscription plan or a single
pair with 20% off your first order when
you go to meet undies comm slash Jenna
Julian that's me undies comm slash Jenna
Julian for 20% off your first order this
episode was also brought to you by bull
and branch bull branch has reimagined
sheets guys they've cut out the
middleman they've cut out the markups
all you do is pick out what you like and
they deliver it to your front door
guys bolin branch has some of the
softest most comfortable bedding towels
sheets everything you need at affordable
prices it really does feel like luxury
right now guys if you go to bull in
branch calm that's bol and branch calm
they will let you try their product
risk-free for 30 nights if you don't
love your sheets your blankets you can
send them back you have nothing to lose
so I got to do is go to bolin branch
calm and you get 20% off your order
your whole order and just use the promo
code Jenna Julian check it out let us
know how you like it tweet us pictures
of your awesome new bed sheets and
towels we currently use them in their
awesome all right now back to the freely
banana girl podcast you're making your
rounds no I made quite a bit of filming
and collabing right that's that's not
normal for you though right it's not
normally my first collab with was with
Joey Graceffa I first climbed
ever-loving very recently yeah yeah that
was really good she does a blue Molly's
right we ate we kinda like peeled them
with our teeth completely it's very open
and messy but it was so much fun yeah
yeah and Shane and Trish last night and
maybe suede Brooks tomorrow and a few
other people it's awesome it's been
amazing you like LA even been my lower
leg I love it
you guys want to him oh we love it we
love it like la all the way it's pretty
awesome the weather is pretty awesome it
is it stays like that I enjoy more than
Australia really do really yeah
I mean I'd like I enjoy Australia
Australia bit yeah we've been it's very
good yeah are you in Sydney winds brief
ice ice lived in Sydney for 11 years but
I'm in Queensland and South Australia
mainly okay which is pretty cool you
know it's definitely cool places there
but I know a lot of opportunities here
and you know the weather is good yeah
heaps cool people worthy fan of the word
are co-heirs although we thought it was
afternoon oh yeah yeah we say oh yes sir
her managers yes Italian to Griffin's in
here names wrong she grew up and said
she says our most she's always like I'll
text you this arvo no [ __ ] I forgot that
means morning or everything that's the
Albert all right oh yeah I didn't come
here to [ __ ] spiders yeah no I thought
she taught us all these Australian
Australian say spider well I'm convinced
that she made a path for them and she
controllers I don't know how that [ __ ]
well as well it's not like you move you
did you find a [ __ ] huntsman I should
really seek what some it is really like
oh you do yeah are you gonna wait for
fine herb they taste good because we
female then a quote advice this is good
outro some of my videos wow I have not
seen you do that it's gonna creep you
out yeah well I feel like I've never
seen one in person losing pictures
yeah we saw one at the zoo though but I
feel like the bigger the spiders somehow
it like humanizes it so it's less scary
but if it's like this big I get really
scared of it okay I don't know guys like
pizza yeah what's there like sorry I'm
uh you're okay yeah the enemies have
some Australia I wanted to do like a
quick background if anyone doesn't know
freely is and you can do this also but
you're probably easily the most visible
vegan youtuber internet personality ever
cuts like something just on your main
channel six hundred eighty two thousand
five hundred ninety seven subscribers as
of earlier today but bar right yeah you
have other channels though to have
another channel like a vlog channel and
then one that got taken down yes one got
taken down yeah
we'll get there on that channel 180
million views
you wrote the you're the author of the
e-book the raw till 4 diet which is
available to download everywhere
shameless plug thank you very much
shameless you changed um you've inspired
a lot of people you've overcome yourself
interaxial bulimia chronic fatigue
syndrome acne you lost 40 pounds it's
about ten years
oh that you were on raw vegan different
a little bit now but you rode your bike
alone across Australia uh yeah anyways
crazy time and you have an Italian
Greyhound in fitzy this concludes
Jenna's summary of your left
Oh hold on today you're gonna go help
what's up to ride across to you it took
me about 40 days Wow yeah I got a bit
lazy and I started doing less and less
K's and I was just calling I didn't know
what that is like breaking across
laziest crazy it sounds impressive yeah
yeah it was it was definitely like a
period of like big growth for me yeah
personal it was at the beginning of you
doing Rob liked the raw food diet it was
pretty much a beginning at first couple
of years yeah yeah and I was just like I
just want to do something and you know
describe spiritually and emotionally and
also lose weight
I think motivator at the time got it and
also to say that because it's the
coolest thing to say i presenting across
australia it's a good resume with me
this is your boyfriend this is my barf
durianrider
harley comes well yeah you got no are
you guys really cousins no that's
they do that in tasmania oh my god you
never say are you really cuz I'm so
gullible like I fall for all that [ __ ]
you said that I'd be like oh good for
you I like it he's trolling off the bat
so it's good the trolley will get along
well yeah um but you guys have been
together for a really long time
yeah I merely know I'm is yes Congrats
on that thank you
um being a journey when when you guys
got together were both of you vegan you
guys are both vegan and then you're our
cycler like a lot did you convert her to
cycling he's like the list he did yeah
basically free we had a con and choosing
in Sydney I was inspired by him doesn't
buy I said come to me come to Adelaide
let me take you on a bloomin outside
life and then you're slipped off your
keys with me away oh yeah we met on like
a real food forum it was called up roll
pleasure Wow exciting bit of real
pleasure and um yeah we just he said I
put up photos of myself on the forum
yeah at the time I was living like a 10
day water fast or something like that
something crazy at the time and I put up
like everyone's I put up like before and
off the phone is put before so I put up
these before-and-after photos and next
thing I know it in my inbox Holly's like
messaging me saying readily do I
counties like this yeah yeah you're just
getting getting real all right and we
didn't have yes your face it mom sorry
so you slid in the DM by arias I'm
coming to sit in the DM must come to
Sydney soon can we like hang out well
you're in the shot now that's all the
nice kids we had left and scramble on
the right all right yeah that server
such a welcome to the homemade nod Qasim
I love this this is awesome well thanks
ah but that's really sweet and you guys
have been together or ever since you
guys ripped another's yeah pretty much
24/7 so you you're like us so like you
guys live and work and should you help
and take that when I watch you a
snapshot so that every guys together so
much I'm like it's rad you know you guys
it takes like extra hard work to put
their relationship first sometimes these
are always together right yeah and you
could always be working in theory if you
wanted to just work everywhere No
right yeah that's interesting we don't
have too many couples that we have a cat
encounter that go through that Omega
Lisa yes you can what kill each other
sometimes support yeah totally a hundred
percent and that it's not even your
fault and you don't even know why you
want to kill them it's like I'm honestly
[ __ ] sick of you right he doesn't
leave me alone yeah okay anyways on to
some other questions because well it's
interesting that you guys were both
vegans and that you met because you were
vegan but I feel like at least with
Julianne because I've been on and off I
was on and off two thousand nine and
then on um after I went full ethical
vegan and really decided that this
wasn't just for health it has like a
trickle-down effect to the people around
you like you did that on YouTube but in
the biggest like you don't have to be in
a relationship with someone you can just
make some videos but I feel like if
you're in proximity with someone that's
vegan but you do tend to make different
choices
Rauf do you think yeah leading by
example yeah it's definitely powerful
hmm I had it with my mom as well my mom
was like uh heck no I'm not going vegan
I don't show me that animal slaughter
unless the other one know anything about
it's a fad diet blah blah and then
within like two years she went vegan so
she really been for like six years
that's just my example yeah interesting
well I want to jump in here as for the
longest time I mean I'm an athlete and I
I had a very hard-nosed kind of
hard-headed mentality I should say where
I'm just like I need my protein all the
time and I can't eat all that fruit you
know all the sugar you know this stuff
you encounter all the time of people
saying this and that and there was a
moment where I really just started to
feel like crap like I was eating me and
I just he's celiac also he can't eat any
nuptial gluten but I'm his diet was
check it was it was chicken it was a lot
of shaking a lot of vegetables and I was
just dis changing and preparing
and there was Secretariat chicken and I
felt horrible I was starting to really
just feel like crap and this is way into
her full vegan stance she's almost been
a year almost now and she was like all
right why don't you just you know try
this one meal at a time why don't you
try one day a week and then it just it's
been four months and I have had any meat
and I like feel incredible yeah I mean
thank you so much no I mean it's but
that's like a trickle down
I just using trickle down yeah sorry you
guys
you especially but you also were as of
more recently although you've always
have you guys get like a lot of [ __ ]
oh yeah oh yeah yeah I think you know at
first it was pretty hard to take because
some of the comments I'm like man people
say she like really yeah really really
brutal and um I mean it's just I know I
understand it's part of the path and if
I take it personally I'm making my
message about me rather than about the
planet and about the animals about the
bigger picture so if I make it about my
ego then I'm really just I'm not making
it you know it's just detrimental to the
cause mm-hm
so if it's going to step away from my
ego and realize don't take it personally
you know some people have to you know
hear the truth and take offense to it
you know three stages a truce a ridicule
violent opposition and then accept it as
fact so some people Island opposition
sounds right some people fight it yeah
yeah so I understand that so when I take
it personally I have to step back and go
hang on this isn't about me you know
calm down like you know right that's
what I do right that helps with haters
or what you feel an experience when you
take your mind off your purpose take
your mind off your passion well if you
were just like a dog and chasing a
rabbit or even just focus locked in it
can't need to see anything else
so if you start reading hate comments
and start drawing it all that excuse
you're not working hard enough work
because you let your mind slip from were
you here for appreciate it then the
haters make you famous
yeah you should be like the first time
in history someone can just have anyone
can do a viral video not even show the
face of a voice just you know it as you
know probably knows people just make
photos of you or whatever would put it
like supplying and YouTube or even put a
go down and so you have to deal with
that hate machine and it's a great
teacher
yes detachment yeah for sure um I will
tell you the first time that I figured
out who you are I was hanging out with
furious Pete the competitive eater
really and I think you had just made a
video about him and it was really
interesting because I had then found out
that you did a video about me and the
people in the comment section and as
someone that had already you know been
vegan for years at a time and then back
and then forth um I didn't perceive your
videos as bullying but you do get a lot
of people that assume that you're
bullying these big youtubers right thank
you for getting it I always get out of
bed like that
oh this that means so much to me like if
you finally every you shave of yeah I
did a video about felt that way that
well I mean cuz you see you've seen
people about you don't make click baby
videos about you because in the ranks
yeah but they'll say oh I'm not about a
clickbait and then they'll make like a
quick video about its icon we're all
essentially about the click bang we want
people to click on our videos to see
whatever message we have what we're
putting out there well the difference is
you have about yes example don't that's
why I feel as well who knows and I've
just appreciate the fact that you do get
it no you can't take it personally and I
remember your comment no comment was
like you just explained you said oh you
know this is that bummer blah he said I
love what you're doing everything like
that and that meant so much to me you
know all your fans are like keep
forgiving each other because I know well
see it's hard for me not to be mad at
them also because I'm like you know
they're coming from a place of caring I
understand like yeah and I'm like guys
the you know maybe should watch the
video she's really just she's the beacon
like we're starting out when you started
making videos and started spreading your
your ideas and your mission like do you
feel like you had to kind of change into
that person you had to be more brash you
had to be more like kind of maybe
polarizing yeah yeah definitely yeah
yeah more so more controversial more in
people's faces and so I that yeah
because it gets attention no it gets
people noticing it if I was just making
videos about you know vegan smoothies
and stuff like that people are going to
click on it I know I'm going to talk
about that after the break to because
I'm like I've a lot off on all good
and you want to become unwatchable and
unhearable really someone watches your
video that can overrun watch it yeah
yeah I did I mean the truth has to leave
an impression on us right to come in
contact with us with it whether we wanna
you know acknowledge it or not it's
still going to leave an impression on us
mmm the seed is planted
it's whether they like it's really yes
there yeah it's there no that's how can
I reach it yeah it's always it's like
you don't have to like them but you're
going to think about them no that's
right yeah I even help it you don't you
don't have to like me you just need to
hear me right that's my little I know
very easy yeah I mean it could be at
first like I said it was hard as like
men like to take on that role of being
hated mm-hmm and just to you know get on
with things but I just keep bringing
myself my mind back to the big picture
and the animals and that helps so much
what's what do you guys have a good
vegan community in Australia I feel like
I see a lot of it online but la is
pretty progressive internet it's
definitely beyond here in LA like yeah
just so you know I have my 28 million
people that's what what do you have you
like 300-mile you know something it's
great its California's 38 million yeah
Wow what is for me yeah it's Kratz
yeah that's insane - yeah the vegan
community here is amazing yeah the man
of restaurants is just it's amazing
Whole Foods have you got a real food
daily yeah yeah we have gonna show them
dinner oh they want to tell our concern
I think it may be Shady
there's one in Hollywood we go to that's
closer to us yeah um like you're La
Cienega or something but I probably move
in right I don't think well yeah that is
your landlords I think I surely would
have you had a Theo you hanging on well
do you do any up yeah it's pretty cool
oh wow yeah baby your hands oh yeah
that's my say I'm just like like in Los
Angeles they do make it like you know
riffle Daly is vegan it's cooked vegan
which may not be your wheelhouse until
4:00 p.m.
yeah yeah uh worse okay but you know
they make it very accessible if I don't
even they're not like oh we're vegan
we're being you're vegan for the
majority of people that haven't
done any research they are like okay not
knowing and it's it's more accessible to
them and there's a lot of places like
that in Los Angeles because we talk
about this all the time with Julian
being celiac and people perceiving
gluten-free is this wonderful diet and
that like the Gwyneth Paltrow's of the
world but it pushes in like when people
have actually a disease when they can't
digest it and it's like a push and pull
of like benefiting you know someone that
really needs it or you know just
everyone's perception of it yeah so like
maybe place it would be nice it was like
we're vegan we're so super proud [ __ ]
everybody but like it is nice that
they're pushing this you know like free
of animal by-products but making it very
accessible people that aren't too keen
on like understanding yeah you know we
need that yeah it resume - yeah exactly
for those of us that are vegan were like
yeah yeah yeah you guys got so much like
right yeah oh yeah Amazon hopefully is
delivered to Houston yeah yeah post and
I got groceries we don't have to leave
you do want to talk about
Rahil for at all because this is like
your thing yeah it wasn't it well my mom
actually coined the term gotta fall but
I kind of designed the program but yeah
and it's awesome it's just eating fruit
for breakfast and lunch and then eating
a high cop cook vegan dinner you know
sounds miserable and I said completely
amazing yeah I can't say that I do it
all day every day but because we are
vegan and it's mostly plant-based it
does end up being like that no sometimes
I'd say we might cook something for
breakfast or lunch yeah but it either I
would really love to try the raw till 4
because don't dull my favorite part of
the rockeo for is after 4:00 when you
get to eat all the rice yeah that's my
patio slice people's favorite bit rice
rice is life yeah
supportive of people even cook food all
day guys in food that's fine for sure I
mean I think fruit it's just it's such
an amazing food and getting in like
those simple sugars and Laghman just so
much nutrition antioxidants and better
carotene all that living nutrition is
really important yeah to get that in at
least for breakfast yeah pick a smoothie
in there and then later on you're not
like wanting heaps of junk food or
wanting to be in jail because you got
that sugar yeah natural fix of shot so
we're doing here one day you can tell a
difference yeah yeah you said it's it's
pretty man you drink that date smoothie
of yours and you can tell a different
way what is that dictator a big day to
read no Gatorade date you just blend
updates and water um as advice as yeah
you can have like a b2 powder and
vanilla so it's like yeah I made it for
Shane and he was I was like a bit
nervous but you trying to like I love
this
yeah really how was Shane whenever tell
us about hanging out with Shane now and
open to vegan yeah he's been around us
yeah he's cool about whatever yeah no
he's just he's a really cool dude
as you know and entertaining and
charismatic yeah listen he's very
entertaining and we made this cool video
last night I won't give away too much
but there's like knives involved and
blood and that's all when you're Shane
in Trisha Paytas and screaming guys if
you want that I mean you're gonna have
to jump on them yeah so you've had quite
a bit of controversy as of lately with
other yeah you got to us yeah ongoing
controversy ain't as easy couple of
weeks you got laid busy's good yeah see
Cassey ho a Blogilates you know and
tanomo job more recently yes but you
want to start with careful
cassie to me is the more interesting in
terms of community because on the
podcast a lot of other youtubers have
talked about whenever something that's
directly affecting the community that
it's just we should talk about it
because it's important because we're
self policing like we should have side
the rules
it's bigger to me though because this
deals with like freedom of speech that's
our honor yes so watching listen for
those who don't know what happened yes I
made a video I made maybe three videos
on Cassie you know they've been um
straight to the point and I've pointed
out where she's not eating you know
healthfully and she's from
loading a calorie restrictive diet
that's the thing and I'm straight to the
point I'm just like here you go this is
what it is I don't call people you know
they've felt disgusting purpose of a
role like that I just point out where
they're eating incorrectly and living
incorrectly and held their
recommendations of affecting the public
and young girls responsible yeah how
it's irresponsible and it's calorie
restrictive I just [ __ ] hate calorie
strict of diet yeah I hate it you know
because I'm being on it myself I've been
helping so many girls you know get out
of that eating disorder cycle yeah it's
hard on themselves it is a second yeah
my money-making son it's horrible so I
made this video this is how years ago by
the way I didn't know that it was years
ago yeah I made this video and just um
maybe two weeks ago I got this
notification that it's been pulled down
one of my videos videos was pulled down
so then strike on my account
Wow yeah and then trying to get other
videos down and I was basically Huy
you were being stifled oh yeah that's
right yeah she's definitely trying to
take my freedom of speech and I'm a big
youtuber she's yeah I have three million
no charges help we would try to help so
defamatory is just he's trying to help
if you watch the video it's not
slanderous it's not defaming of her at
all and just trying to help her and her
audience and you always put that little
fair-use thing in the beginning of your
video someone freelee's not you didn't
come here to [ __ ] spiders yes thank you
but your honor fortunately have to do
that you're like but you're your abiding
by that law and even just by putting it
there you're reminding everyone like
look I'm allowed to use this as fair use
and I'm allowed to react and say what I
want to say yeah exactly so yeah it was
really it was sad to me because I've
seen Cassie kind of stepping up and
putting on vegandon yeah yeah and like
talking about metabolic damage and how
she's ever going to die it again and all
this great stuff I'm like wow Cassie's
on the path that something's happening
here but then I thought well maybe she's
trying to I don't know cash in on the
vegan movement it's hard to say but then
when I got this notification the first
notification I'm like cheese girl like
why yeah the [ __ ] you doing so you're
getting flagged under copyright yeah
she's saying you have somehow violated
your copyright abilities by using
portions of her video even though it
would involve Aereo's yeah which wasn't
ideas if what I mean full disclosure I
don't really know her personally uh you
know I'm sure she's a nice girl or
whatever but I'm not coming at this
because I'm also vegan in my views align
with your views I genuinely think it's a
big problem on YouTube stop doing yeah
you cannot get someone else's voice
because you don't like what they have to
say yeah you know let alone all the
other shifty things my question for you
was uh have you had any personal contact
with her how do you talk to her about it
not at all she's just she put up like
maybe about seven Twitter post about it
like saying someone he's just kept
fooling me someone yeah everyone in the
comments is like never really went yeah
no we saw the comments yes it's not a
passive aggressive communication but she
couldn't you know she could have
messaged me or email and said hey like
you know can we talk about this video
that you got up I don't like it can we
talk about it but no she went straight
for the legal roof Wow and it is and
people understand that it is a legal you
know legally binding document like it's
not just some a lot of people being like
you know it's only like you know it's
people get it they just it's cool
Content ID they automatically get it
down it's not that that's actually a
felon in the US is it today all the
false digital media copyright claim I
could see her but what's that going to
do for ya exactly we're gonna be
spending a whole ton of money wasting
our time well planets in the you know
situation is yeah right um I guess my
next question is you know if you had any
contact with her and do you think that
maybe this is just her because I like to
give people the benefit of the doubt you
know maybe she's being ill advised by
people to do this to you maybe yeah I
feel like she is a bit of a puppet to
some degree because well if you have a
company that's making as much money as
she's probably making you know there's a
lot of people with their hands in that
cookie jar that's he's not trying to
tell you what you should do Randi that
could be true that could be true
definitely she took the step to do it
well she could have been ill-advised for
sure she didn't hat no one was holding a
gun to her head
like right these tweets making fun of
freely yeah holding a banana gun yeah
yeah yeah that's true
I mean like I feel like maybe she's
bringing something else maybe like a
book or maybe something's big biggest
coming out and she wants to clean up her
her brand like they might have searched
on YouTube and my video comes up I want
to get this out as I can't have that
yeah there's ways to do that though
there's ways to do that without you know
attacking you legally yeah I know
is it an email yeah I feel like it's not
an evil thing to do to another youtuber
I don't know I just really the Rope lady
and that's not the it enables Paris for
a censored internet I feel like it's
bringing the corporate world into the
YouTube community and I feel like that
should not should never happen I agree
with that statement 100% huh you see how
much effort you put into channel would I
use and everyone and everyone is your
lively you put up on your chocolate your
someone's ability to pay their bills and
earn a living anyone understands how
important it is to not [ __ ] with
youtubers channel and they're legally
you know legally making videos in their
livelihood
it's another YouTube yeah not I mean if
anyone's gonna get it it's nothing if
somebody was doing that to me I'd be
like oh hell I know I see these stories
about people getting strikes and fake
claims I'm like oh my god that sounds
like the worst thing ever it's just such
a headache and I mean in theory it would
be nice if YouTube stepped in and was
like look guys this is ridiculous they
just they just implemented the new thing
we're not friends well during the
dispute so say someone files a claim
they want to monetize on your video say
they want to claim it or whatever during
the dispute cuz you can file a dispute
during that period the money that is
getting her in a video goes into a
separate account oh and a winner gets
all that money whereas before whoever
had claimed was automatically getting
the money yeah you know until they try
until they figure it out so yeah that's
a solution proposed by youtubers exactly
this isn't yes sitting around and talk
right under a was a big big reason why
that happened he's a lot of channels
were talking about that video and the
fact that it got so much attention
Susan the CEO was like okay we're
listening on that's good yeah and it's
it was very impressive there might be
hope for you without having to go fight
your own legal battle yeah that it will
get rectified but it still sucks in the
time being that you're unfairly being
censored yeah it does suck as well and
you know I don't care if she wants to
monetize the video I couldn't care less
but I like to put a strike on my
accountant right and continue to try and
get videos down it's just really I think
that's wrong hmm you know especially if
she's gonna post some vegan videos I
think there's another thing too like I
think a lot of youtubers bigger
youtubers get me wrong they think I'm
scary later scared of me mmm do you know
Naveen again like it's horrible
aggressive person should we attack you
because they think they're gonna be
attack yeah they misinterpreted my
passion yeah you know I mean yeah you
know it's zeal its passion it's not like
hate and yeah you know I'm just like
passion for anger I don't know if you
watched it or know who Hank green is the
youtuber geena's vlogbrothers I've heard
of you yet he they created VidCon him
and his brother John Green and John Gray
is the novelist that wrote like The
Fault in Our Stars and all that stuff
they're brilliant really smart and he
made a really nicely put from a
carnivore perspective why vegans and
vegetarians are so annoying and it
boiled down to is that they're right and
we don't want to hear it
well where is that me it's online hey
Hank conscience still titled why vegans
and vegetarians are so annoying or
something like I know check that out but
he's like really wonderfully thoughtful
and brilliant he's a he's incredibly
well-spoken very smart right
yeah and I really do want to just say
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast I feel like it's you know if
anyone made it this far in the podcast
and you I felt a certain way about
freely beforehand I really hope that
listening to a conversation did
something where you can see her as a
human being check out a videos a real
message absolutely check out our channel
check out her but try not to take things
personally when you watch your head I
get yourself some me Andy's get yourself
some bowling brown sheets
links in the description and we see you
guys next week